bah écoutez la gauche bon d'abord elle
se comporte de manière civile et
respectueuse et grossi c'est quand même
mieux que les ébulons de l'Assemblée
nationale mais sur le fond qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils font des amendements
identiques
qu'ils défendent les uns derrière les
autres pour dire la même chose et
derrière ils ont je ne sais combien
d'explications de votes moi j'en suis à
ma cinquième réforme des retraites comme
je suis un parlementaire qui a quelques
heures de vol et je me souviens d'avoir
présidé une séance quand j'étais
vice-président de l'Assemblée nationale
où on acceptait que un orateur par
groupe sur les explications de votre
parce que ce qui intéresse évidemment le
peuple de France c'est de savoir quels
sont les arguments échangés et
évidemment à partir du moment où les
rapporteurs qui sont excellents
Madame doanneau et Monsieur Savary
donnent la position majoritaire de la
commission la réponse est faite si vous
voulez donc on ne va pas aller dans des
débats
qui vont s'éterniser parce que si le but
c'est qu'on ne vote pas cette loi au
final nous c'est pas notre but nous nous
voulons que la loi qui est celle du
Sénat c'est-à-dire ce n'est pas celle du
gouvernement le Sénat va fortement
améliorer cette loi que cette loi soit
votée au final mais ça veut dire que
mise à part les parlementaires de gauche
il y a que la Commission qui doit
s'exprimer dans ce débat sur les régimes
sociaux la droite n'a rien à dire à part
pour ce qui est malade on doit nous pour
les
centristolet de représentant la majorité
sénatoriale si on avait ce que je vous
ai je viens de vous dire qui se passe de
temps en temps et que le règlement
permet ça dire un orateur pour un
orateur contre évidemment que on aurait
un orateur qui viendrait être contre les
amendements de suppression de la gauche
mais là en l'occurrence le but est de
faire traîner les choses en longueur on
va pas tomber dans ce piège de rajouter
du temps au temps on a dit les choses si
on veut justifier un effort important
des Français pas ça 64 ans c'est un
effort important demandé aux Français si
on veut justifier l'effort il faut
fortifier la justice du texte donc nous
ce qui nous intéresse c'est la suite
c'est à dire qu'on peut qu'on puisse
faire plus pour les maires de famille
qu'on puisse clarifier le dispositif des
carrières l'ont compris scarifier les
questions de pénibilité et qu'au final
on est plus de justice parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est profondément ajuste
expliquez-moi puisqu'on parle de régime
spéciaux pourquoi elle conducteur
d'autobus en ma métropole lilloise lui
il est condamné à avoir un régime comme
tous les Français et que la RATP ils
peuvent partir entre 52 et 57 ans il y a
une injustice profonde et donc il faut
réparer cette injustice
[Musique]